hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
hey guys it's John Humphrey we're gonna
watch the trailer for Stevens movie
ready player one oh it's the morning
that rhythm when you
[Music]
[Music]
to a every line those days have to be
over okay people are concerned about
having a woman in charge of the paper
then she doesn't have the resolve to
make the tough choices thank you or your
friends what is it you think we do here
for a living
you must be precious cargo it's just
government secrets will be the Supreme
Court next week
to risk her fortune and the company
that's been her entire life
Hey Washington ceased to exist
Nixon will muster the full power of the
presidency and if there's a way to
destroy you god they'll find the legacy
of the company is at stake
[Music]
we will lose the country will lose
[Music]
what are you going to do
damn fake news fake news is all fake
it's all fake but the very bad Tom Hanks
nobody likes movies anymore ask anyone I
haven't seen a spill Burton movie in a
few years yeah I missed out on bridge of
spies The BFG war horse war horse and
adventures of tintin Simon yes I haven't
been up to date with Spielberg movies in
a while I saw most of Lincoln my most
first half
I think there's a lot of great things to
be excited for here a Oscar bait
Oscar is always an exciting thing that's
why it's a January movie getting limited
release in December scurs
this looks both you know timely in
multiple ways but also thrilling yeah
well III think this could be a passion
project I'm sure what everyone's really
excited for is things that I yeah i'm
excited for - it means spielberg getting
together Tom Hanks and Meryl Streep in
one movie is pretty friggin excited yeah
there's a huge ensemble here that looks
amazing Sarah Paulsen seeing here Bob
Odenkirk you see in the trailer Alison
Brees in this movie Bruce Greenwood
Roose Greenwood dude Jesse Plemons and
also who's the who's the guy from get
out the president Bradley Whitford yeah
but Tom Hanks specifically I watched the
CNN documentary that he produced of all
about the 60s do deal with the Vietnam
War and there's one episode that was
really heavily dedicated to the
importance and power of journalism where
they would cut back to interviews with
Tom Hanks there and I feel like this
might be the only unique feedback I can
provide it would cut back to Tom Hanks
showing how much insight he had on the
impact of what journalism was and I feel
like for us Millennials like we get our
news from a great filter la la Times
articles off the internet you know until
we reach our limit yeah I feel like Tom
Hanks might be giving a
passion of performance here based off
the topic of the impact and how
important journalism was especially with
revealing conspiracies of things along
the lines dealing with Nixon and whatnot
yeah it's cool to see an actor take on a
role that you can tell yeah he cares
about yeah yeah I like the character
affectations he's got going here like
Tom Hanks doesn't always put on you know
mannerisms but just sometimes and I
really like watching him sing the lady
kiss I know nobody likes them Meryl
Streep I can't wait to get dominated
check yeah sometimes all you gotta do is
see a trailer of Meryl Streep see hints
of what she's doing like okay I just got
an Oscar nomination there you go well
she'll probably win though cuz like
Donald Trump like picked it personally
so Hollywood will take that over to
Oscar for you don't even think about
that that's so true oh yeah she's the
one taking down the president what's a
feminist empowerment film - there's
there's a lot of relevant things that
one line man when that dudes like you
know we don't think you have the resolve
and she takes like a second and she
looks at him and just you know like I
can't remember the exact spring Frank
yeah it's like what a poised response
I'm very excited yeah looks like a solid
thriller man a solid political thriller
that it will have some good humor there
there's some notable Spielberg types of
cinematography and shots here awesome
master angles
I feel like silver is really good at
mixing you know just good film work with
some frames to that shot in such a wide
frame were like you can kind of choose
where you want to look yeah there's
something happening kind of everywhere
in the sea yeah Bob Odenkirk looks like
he might be a bit of a scene stealer
when he's in front of the camera oh I
feel like he always is he he has such a
cool career cuz he can walk freely
between dramas and comedies as he
pleases
ah man what happened to good old
journalism you know got me to appreciate
those feet dared oh yeah character there
who's like I'm a Bruin journalism used
to be known as blogs and yeah
the post you can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell we are on social media make sure to
check out our patreon become a patriotic
jet today could be worth your time might
be working line it could be worth
everyone's including jobs take care